the girl on my show the one who I was
like okay this is I'm gonna tell you
this story okay I'm sorry I'm all over
the place she may give the names away
look at look at Amy and and she comes on
my show and
she okay I did we're talking a show
about body count right how many bodies
too many questions like that I don't
usually the only time I ask people their
body count is when I say is body count
important and they say no and then I say
then what's your body count but the
point isn't to get their body count the
point is to show it's important right
because otherwise everyone would just be
like this you know so um on this show as
a joke I was like what's your guys's
body count I said haha you don't have to
say it's okay like I was kidding she's
all this Pro sex girl so she's like oh
I'll say it to get rid of the stigma are
you sure she says yes okay go ahead go
ahead this girl threatens to sue me
because she said her body count on live